boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are on site at the raw Science Film
Festival the fifth annual one where we
are awarding incredible humans for
disseminating scientific wisdom and
inspiration to generation to the next
generations we are super excited and
honored to be talking to the producers
and directors of burden of genius we
have Laura
we have Chartists and we have Karl
joining us thank you so much for coming
onto the show and talking to us it's
actually quite an honor because I was
crying during the screening of their
film because it was dr. Thomas Starzl
correct
Starzl who was a major pioneer in in
surgical and circle transplant
transplant surgery of the liver and they
did a gorgeous job of illustrating the
burden of genius that it takes to run
through walls of adversity and be able
to impact 125,000 liver surgeries have
now happened over the span of like 4050
years and he taught so many people to
become surgeons around the world I am I
was just bawling so I want to hear from
you about the importance of what you did
why it's so important to you and what we
can take away from it because to me I
made the comparison to the Wright
brothers as one of the also burdens of
genius of so many deaths so much hard
work so many walls of adversity to help
us have over a hundred thousand
commercial flights happening around the
world every single day now so so many
people are doing this so please tell us
about your journey and the importance of
this
please you well let's see it really was
kind of a gem that was dropped in our
lap when we you know Carl actually
conceived the idea to you know to do the
film and we started doing interviews
with dr. Starzl in 2014 and we only did
a few interviews at the time about five
interviews with people who you know with
him about fifteen hours over the course
of a week and then other people who had
worked closely with him and at that
point you know we were still looking for
the rest of the money so so I went off
and I and I edit that's you know a short
sizzle reel let's say it was about 14
minutes or so in order to raise the rest
of the money and and then we on his 90th
birthday there were people coming from
all over the world who had been trained
by him back to pay homage to to him so
we were really lucky to get all these
people who we never could have
interviewed all those people so we
really did a marathon of interviews of
the course of a weekend were able to
interview probably over 35 people I
would say and ended up with about 70
hours worth of interviews and then the
idea was you know I mean with the
documentary there's not really a script
you you you know it's the it's the
interviews that that are the glue that
holds it all together so that it was
about going through all the interviews
and and pulling takes from that and I
think the first cut was like eight hours
was just talking heads at this point you
know and then slowly compress it you
know get rid of all the repetitions and
kind of find the structure you know and
its really kind of written in the
editing room in that way and you know
and Laura did all the interviews which
were fantastic because I mean it you
know that's what I think you're hoping
for is that you have you know if the
interviews are goals you can make a good
documentary that's what it comes down to
you know if they're really heartfelt and
so so we really were very lucky that
that doctor Starzl Trust has trusted us
enough to really be able to tell it all
yes so I just wanted to say why we have
to tell the story and why we want
science is so important this is one of
the greatest stories never told because
of exactly what you said it's easy in
the rear view mirror to say that's how
the polio vaccine happened transplants
and immunology have changed modern
medicine it's a greatest significant
thing that happened most people don't
know who dr. Starzl is but the reason it
was so important is you can't repeat
what it takes to do scientific progress
until you see this film and what they
put together to really feel the impact
of you know I have first of all when dr.
Ted Koppel was accusing him of literally
putting people's lives at risk why are
you doing this and of course now all
around the world this is being
replicated so that's really why it's
great to be here to do this and it
occurred to me that until you really not
only have made the thumb but begun to
show it but in some ways you don't even
know fully what your own film is about
and I realized now that the most
important thing I think about the film
is somebody said earlier he chose to do
the hardest thing imaginable the
impossible thing and that's so inspiring
to me and that there was no career ISM
it was just about wanting to help people
overcome a seemingly insurmountable
problem and I would hope that students
so we made it for everyone of course but
I hope that students whether it's middle
school kids college kids medical
students will see this and take that
kind of inspiration because you don't
know who is the next Starzl who is the
next Elon Musk who is the next Steve
Jobs hopefully they'll be a little nicer
than some of those people but I mean the
size of their thinking and the way
they've changed things and will continue
to change things I think is really what
the film is about
there's there this sort of mentality of
putting everything on the line for the
advancement of humanity and some sort of
regard across some sort of scientific
discipline that just pushes our edge of
knowledge further and and just augments
life in so many ways that inspiring that
in in the next generations is so
important and I and I hope to see more
film from you that does that for other
than other people continues that and
seeing this in in schools like we were
talking about as well showing this film
in schools what do you guys have on the
roadmap well I could say in terms of
distribution we come from Pittsburgh
where mr. Rogers believed that education
in the classroom could change the world
and the truth of the matter is there
isn't great ways of getting media into
education we have Greg we're gonna see
this movie on tour around the country
and around the world it's already
screening from India to Dallas but the
real important thing is to partner with
educators organ donation organizations
when people see this movie they change
their organ donation status and we're
working with all the medical people
around the world and that's why
festivals like want science can really
elevate you know what we see but we
really need to put together the people
in there the educators with the people
from media to make sure it gets to the
classroom so in the next year if they
just go to burden of genius film calm
they can see it around the world and
they can follow and it'll be in their
neighborhood soon thanks Tom comm is
links in the bio for that and on so next
is just distribution then yeah well we
actually are trying to put together a
twenty city tour and we have a lot of
requests to do the movie so they'll
should be in some theaters and then
it'll be available in about a year for
the general public so thanks ok thank
you guys so much really appreciate even
the short bit I look forward to a longer
form conversation about the burden of
genius at some point thank you all three
of you thank you everyone thank you
thank you
I will I will I will definitely let you
know thank you thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it
you guys had a good time let us know
your thoughts in the comments below also
guys the burden of genius is so
important really embody this really go
and create build go through walls of
adversity much love check out the link
in the bio and we'll see you soon peace